I am ready to figure out which regret
belongs to which person starting with
the studying abroad I'm going to give
that one to Freddy Navy Seals I'm going
to give that to gadiel ignoring my
culture I'm going to give that to
Carolina Pussycat Dolls hoodie I'm going
to give that to JZ and then dancing
regret I'm going to give that to
Ivon
how's that possible I didn't say nothing
how' you figure it out the less you say
the more you're saying the more you were
saying about being confident you were
trying to redirect me from something
that was clearly more simplistic by
making it more complex wow we're always
speaking to one another we're always
connecting with one another